foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
making his weekly pit stop and his more
to it podcast on The Dan Patrick Podcast
network is a hit around the country and
uh it's available it's Sports
entertainment cultural and he touches on
all those different Landscapes there the
more to it podcast with Marcellus Wiley
wherever you get your podcast or sell us
joining us on the program let me give
you the poll question here Satan give
the poll question to Marcellus I'm most
concerned about Patrick Mahomes ankle
Joe Burrows Cockiness Jalen hurt
shoulder or Brock Purdy's inexperience
Echo that's number one uh because that's
tangible that's actually physical you
think about Joe burrow and his
confidence or his Cockiness I think that
actually leads the charge for these
Bengals when they find themselves in
dire situations they lean on Joe burrow
and his impossible mentality of I can
conquer all uh you talk about the
shoulder injury we had with Jalen hurts
he's been through that before I think
he's learned how to recover from that
Brock Purdy's in an interesting place
he's in a place where he doesn't know
the magnitude of the moment as much as
everyone is advertising it to him so in
those moments before you get to really
recalibrate before you have the off
season to Exhale before defenses happen
off season to game plan against you
you're still just gonna ride that wave
but Patrick Mahomes is coming into this
game compromised mentally and physically
he knows he's not going to be in the
same situation he was last week with the
adrenaline blowing the needle poking
into the ankle to give him that great
medicine all of that's going to change
for my homes I also wonder because so
much of the game is reactionary that now
he's got to think when he is maybe going
to have to escape the pocket he might
have to almost recalibrate in the moment
to say I can't I can't do that or I
shouldn't do that athletes normally
don't play that way
yeah the best athlete is Mindless the
glow The Zone when you're not thinking
through it it's all Instinct and when
you're compromising you're going through
the work week the toughest part is
you're always going to give yourself a
physical exam so you get out of bed you
put your ankle down oh that doesn't feel
good okay you go to the kitchen you're
like all right Brittany let me go let me
try and go to the table oh that doesn't
feel good you go to practice you're not
practicing and now you're starting to
get out of sync with your normal Rhythm
and then you get on the game field even
after the injections even after you get
all the medicine and you're hyped in the
crowd you're still thinking about your
ankle every single step so that's a
different athlete that's a slower
athlete a guy who's not in the zone so
Patrick Mahomes certainly will be
compromised the game plan will have to
be edited all things will change just
because of that ankle and this is a
Bengals defense that a lot of people
haven't uh spotlighted but you've
already contained Josh Allen so you've
contained a you know a running
quarterback or quarterback who can run
uh how do they approach Patrick Mullen
if you were a defensive player playing
against Patrick Mahomes Super Bowl on
the line
you go for a tackle
how do you tackle him do you do anything
that might be bordering on
uh it wouldn't border it would cross the
border absolutely you got to build a
wall because I'm crossing this border I
am trying to vote of course are you
kidding me I give Patrick Mahomes out
this game I got Chad Henny no disrespect
but not the same amount of respect
that's the difference first year first
point was great the Cincinnati Bengals
defense did not get its proper due last
postseason when they really carried this
team to that Super Bowl appearance they
were the real MVP when Joe burrow was
kind of riding a roller coaster in the
postseason once again that defense shows
up as well so now you go against
packable homes and you know he's not
mobile he's limited and it's impossible
for you to fear something you don't
respect and guess what I don't respect
that Patrick Mahone's contest us right
now I don't respect the attached to my
homes is going to get outside his pocket
and do damage so now we don't fear that
so now our game plan gets to now shrink
their offense to just what are you gonna
do in the running game what are you
going to do in the quick passing game
because you're not going to let them go
three five seven step drop you're going
to have a Miss shotgun dink dunk and
hopefully air it out here and there all
of that plays into the hands of the
Cincinnati Bengals what a defense that
is playing at a Super Bowl level if Joe
burrow wins this game
in Kansas City
now we might put an asterisk by it if
Mahomes isn't completely healthy but
does he Leap Frog does he who does he
Leap Frog in the uh quarterback list
if anybody um he he's the head of Justin
Herbert already just because of
post-season success let's just go there
even though I like Herbert better as a
quarterback I digress uh Josh Allen
watch your back Josh Allen look out
because now you're going to see a Joe
burrow who's been to two Super Bowls
regardless of winning them he's been to
two Super Bowls where Josh Allen with
all of his talent and all of his
tangibles and everything he does for
that offense and for the Buffalo team
where's your Super Bowl appearance and
Joe burrow coming off that collegiate
career that perfect last season he was
already riding that wave and his
intangibles line up with a Tom Brady
just a different display of them because
he is greater than some of his Parts you
can add up Joe burrow as a scout and say
okay I give him a 90 grade but somehow
some way he goes on the field and gives
you a 95 and that's why you look at his
intangibles they relate to a Tom Brady
who is someone who's gonna play better
than all the things that they have going
adding up sometimes we look at the
quarterbacking position you go well that
guy wouldn't win the punt passing kick
contest
and and Josh Allen would win the punt
pass and kick uh or Justin Herbert Mike
Joe Burroughs not going to I want you to
react to this Marvin would you play the
Jim Gray question to Tom Brady about his
future
time you're leaving everybody guessing
uh and you said you'll take your time do
you have any type of a timetable as to
what you might want to do uh regarding
your football career Jim if I knew what
I was gonna do I'd have already
done it okay I'm taking a day at a time
okay so uh
it is he being cranky is being serious
is he like what's the context of that
answer
Oh My grandmother used to say the way
you go in is the way you're gonna go out
and what that means is Tom Brady was a
six-round pick number 199 and no one
gave a damn about how long Tom Brady was
going to play nobody even gave a damn
about if Tom Brady was going to play
into the sixth round right so you always
had that in your ticker and then when
you get to a place where everyone is
clamoring for your every word your every
moment your every move you can never
negotiate that feeling out of your life
so when you get to this place where you
truly don't know and you've been
bombarded with the same question every
single day you go back to the beginning
you go back to the foundation which is
dude you didn't give a damn a check for
me then so why the hell are you checking
for me now and it comes out as cranky
but Tom Brady is really in a place of
indifference he does not know he knows
the positives but he's also smart and
enough to calculate the negatives of
returning potential impact to Legacy
potential impact in terms of injury and
how it's going to display in his family
life this is a different Tom Brady
existence so I wouldn't call it cranky
I'll just tell everyone that Tom Brady's
a little bit tired of you checking on
him when you're in check on him in the
beginning do you have any problem with
the Cowboys Twitter site saying Dak
Prescott gave away the ball twice and
the narrow loss to the 49ers in a
matchup the Cowboys had a chance to win
if they didn't again generate
self-inflicted wounds it's still up on
the Cowboys Twitter page yeah I do have
a problem with it um The Friendly Fire
of it all like you know you're going to
highlight my indiscretions my issues on
the field knowing that this is the
Ultimate Team game and knowing that what
you're really trying to do is trying to
get cover for what the Dallas Cowboys
reputation has been for the last 25 plus
years which is no postseason success so
now now you're going to use me as the
poster child for something that is
greater than me not only in the moment
is it greater than me if Tony Pollard
plays that entire game I'm here to tell
you guys that the Dallas Cowboys
advanced in that game just because every
time he gets the ball it could be
instant six now you put it all on deck
and obviously the turnovers but still if
you're Dak Prescott you have to feel
like this is coming from higher than the
social media Department sometimes in the
organization they're disconnected
sometimes they're taking their marching
orders from someone higher if I were
that I would feel like Jerry Jones had
his hand in this I would feel like
someone of a senior level of executive
had their hand in this and that will
make me feel really uncomfortable well I
don't know what is
otter you know the fact that it was
posted or the fact that it's still up
there because if Jerry Jones wanted this
down it would be down
correct yeah I mean exactly you think
about it one did it get to Jerry Jones
yet like some things you know first of
all if you got billions and billions of
dollars are you paying attention to all
these things are your handlers coming to
you and telling you hey man you know
there's some noise out there about this
and who doesn't survive better and love
and thrive in the noise more than Jerry
Jones that said it does seem like it's a
conspiracy it does seem like it's
connected to higher authority which is
trying to send a message to that on the
podcast this week uh why Shannon sharp
held Court Courtside against the uh the
Grizzlies
um
button right
oh what right it was dead wrong like the
the worst part of it all is this Shannon
sharp I played against Shannon Sharpe he
gave me the business my rookie year
that's when they won their back-to-back
Super Bowls in Denver I remember him
holding me and laughing at me and giving
me life lessons during the play he
literally said hey this game is about
Eminem's money and memories young man
you'll learn it I'm like let me go I'll
figure that out later right so I got
lots of love for Shannon sharp but he's
been on that field he's been in the heat
of battle and he's heard the hecklers
he's seen the hecklers and not once has
he ever said let me jump in the third
row and see what's up so why would you
now flip that on Dylan Brooks in the
Grizzlies premeditated show up to the
actual game Courtside and think that
they're going to cross that line when
you never cross that line it just seemed
like it was a traveling circus like you
know we have this element in media now
where we're trying to go viral at any
cost and it just felt like like that was
one of those moments that was so like
lacking authenticity and it just seemed
like it was thirsting for attention
he since apologized yesterday Mark
that's smart yeah but how would that
have played out if
Dylan Brooks went over there oh nobody
broke it up
Steven Adams
there you go now you're talking now
Dylan Brooks went over there it'd be
Shannon sharp one Dylan Brooks and
grizzly zero but when Aquaman shows up
when Stephen that seven foot Aquaman
showed up we got problems and Steven
Adams if everyone watching that video
One More Time watch the security guard
that goes to Steven Adams first he got
put in the washing machine like Stephen
that was like like move man but you know
thing no one wants to throw hands no
one's out there to fight it serves no
one's greater good to fight so therefore
all of the wolf tickets that are being
sold and come here and what if you it's
like dog we are grown men with lots of
commas on our checks why are you acting
like this and broadcasting this to the
world sometimes we look at uh a football
player and we go man that guy's big and
then you see Shaq and then you go no no
that's big like a basketball player is
big football players can be jacked but
you know you look at some of these
basketball players and it's like Yao
Ming now that it's a big man yeah and he
has the leverage to reach you from
across the court right that's the thing
so you look at Shannon sharp he's he's
muscular I mean he's yoked up those are
big muscles but Shaq Steven Adams those
are big mammals like you gotta look out
for those dudes man they come at you
it's gonna be a whole different game
plan the podcast is more to it and it's
available on danpatrick.com wherever you
get your podcast you uh you're gonna
you're gonna pick your Super Bowl teams
you're going to talk about the uh Mark
uh the Marcellus Wiley curse and a few
other things on the podcast this week uh
did all your former teams lose this
weekend oh whatever
hey like like I said
I said well Championship where's your
playoff success I said I have bad
teammates that's all I can say and now I
guess I have bad organizations because
we can't even win when I'm not on the
field it's crazy uh if you're handling
the bills though
you got big issues
and small issues big issues big issues
bigger than being advertised because
Brian daybowl left and when he left he
took some of the punch from this offense
they just put it all on Josh Allen
leading rusher almost every week Josh
Allen oh it's fine because Josh Allen is
amazing the problem is when you get to
the playoffs no one allows you to go
plan a it's all Plan B where's your
curveball not your fastball and that's
the problem with this offense right now
McDermott's a great coach but I think
him being defensive minded he needs
another day ball in there or else things
are going to be ugly thank you Marcellus
have a great week all right appreciate
you Dan Marcellus Wiley great podcast
great reaction to it we'll take a break
some phone calls coming up back after
this